Speaker 1: Many of you over the last 24 or 48
hours wrote to me about some very particular
statements made by former 60 Minutes journalist
Lara Logan that are, quite frankly, utterly
deranged. Now, I don't know how many in the
audience know the trajectory of Lara Logan, but
Lara Logan was at one point sort of a respectable
journalist, and she has increasingly gone down the
conspiracy rabbit hole. Over the last year, we've
talked about her anti-Semitic conspiracy theories,
anti-vaccine conspiracy theories, COVID medical
disinformation, just sort of all of the above type
thing. I don't know whether this is a character
she's playing or whether she really is off the
rails. But I am going to show you a couple
of clips of what happens when you really are
infected by proverbial brain worms. Lara Logan
was interviewed by Newsmax two days ago and she
claims to have spoken to a man who infiltrated the
global cabal at the U.N. Even she seems confused
by what she's claiming. It is very scary stuff. I
would get the kids out of the room for this one.
Speaker 2: But you know what? It's even bigger
than that because I you know, I spoke to a man
who was actually holding the documents in his
hand. He told me about it. Right. He said he was
he infiltrated the global cabal at the UN level.
Right. And one of the things that he was able to
to to tell me about from his own personal
experience, what he witnessed himself was
these documents that show that the plan
there is a plan. And this was several years
ago. Right. The plan was to infiltrate
100 million illegal immigrants. And at
that point, they were already at 40 million.
Speaker 1: Now, think about how insane this is.
Infiltrate 100 million undocumented immigrants to
the United States, a third of the US population.
I mean, it does no matter what state you live
in. This doesn't even pass the sniff test. Just
think about what that would mean in terms of our
daily lives. It's not even remotely plausible.
Speaker 2: And these people would dilute
what they called the Pool of Patriots
souls with their words, right? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, that's that's great
replacement stuff. We've talked about that for
a while. That's the idea of a concerted plan
by Democrats to replace white people with
nonwhite people in order to control this.
That and this is Tucker Carlson stuff, but
just with slightly less eloquent language.
Speaker 2: And they would not be taught
that America is a great country and trained
to sing the national anthem with pride.
Speaker 1: And they wouldn't be trained
to sing the national anthem. Think
about that language. We train people
to sing the national anthem with pride. So
it sounds pretty authoritarian, fascistic.
Speaker 2: Someone, and so on. They would
be taught all the negative things that we're
taught about the US today that our own children
are taught. And what would be the effect of
diluting the pool of patriots? Well, it would
be to break down this sense of pride in being
American and what it means to be American.
Speaker 1: Yeah, really, really scary stuff.
And to think that just I don't know, what
was it a decade ago? She really was a
pretty respectable journalist doing pretty
respectable journalism. She also you know,
it's it's not just anti-science. It's not just
conspiracies, but it's also this pseudo religious
stuff where she's not necessarily saying that
these are her Christian beliefs, but she's talking
about Satan as if Satan is a sort of conscious
actor with agency. Listen to this bonkers stuff.
Speaker 3: That's right out of it's right out
of the playbook. The right out of the socialist
playbook. Divide and conquer. You don't tell
me your intent. You get people to come in. You
got you useful idiots. Those of us who are
paying for these people to have all these
luxuries and they lie about it, how does it end?
Speaker 2: Well, it is bad for some. Okay. So on
a serious note and you know, people of all faiths
have said to me that this is a spiritual battle. I
am a firm and solid and immovable believer in God.
Speaker 1: Now understand that. What do you mean
you're saying? The Muslims came to you and
that this is a spiritual battle against
immigrants who are mostly religious also.
The Jews came to you. The Buddhists,
everybody's coming to you saying, Lara,
these are really battles of faith against the
immigrants. What the hell are you talking about?
Speaker 2: And I believe that God wins. I believe
that good is greater than evil. And I believe
that the fallen angel, otherwise known as Satan,
doesn't get to prevail in this world. Wow. So if
you follow the Bible or if you follow the Koran or
you follow the Book of Mormon, you know, people
talk in various different ways about the end
times. And if you fight for God.
Speaker 1: The end times,
guys, the end times.
Speaker 2: God will fight
for you but part of humanity.
Speaker 1: Final thought.
Speaker 3: Final thought, though. I have to I
have to ask you this, because my my audience
is very God fearing, God loving, etc.. Final
thought and only couple of seconds, please.
Is God okay with a close border?
Speaker 2:
It's much bigger than that. God believes
that in sovereignty and national identity
and the sanctity of family and all
the things that we've lived with.
Speaker 1: God also has chosen Ford over
Chevy. He's really weighing in on every issue.
Speaker 2: We have time and he knows that the
open border is Satan's way of taking control of
the world through all these people who are his
stooges and his and his servants. And they may
think that they're going to become gods. That's
what they tell us. Yuval Noah Harari and and all
the rest that them at the World Economic Forum,
you know, the ones who want us eating insects,
cockroaches, and that while they dine on the
grandchildren. Those are the people right there.
Speaker 1: I love how Eric BOLLING
is like. Right. Because, you know,
the ones that want us eating the insects and the
cockroaches and dining on the blood of children.
Right? Right. Who's sicker? The person saying
this stuff, the host taking it seriously or the
audience members who believe it? I don't have the
answer, but they're all pretty sick in my book.